I'm talking to dave irvine who was
a former riveter in the workshops during
the building of the sydney harbour bridge
. Do you remember first getting the job
the yes i remember getting the job
i came and mr.
Martin. I met him in sydney in 1926. And
he asked me when i take a job on there as
a matter of fact i had written to dorman
long's in england when i was home an
island and they tell me i
came to the site of a make up
a case of bridge up there. So
i came in 1926 a moment mr.
Martin offered me the job and i was the
first really on the job in the shops and
how long were you working
there in the shops five and
a half years. I left there and run
december thirty one. Do you remember the
process of riveting exactly how it was
done. Well you want me to go through that
hydraulic and pure magic right through.
Well the hydraulic riveting was made there
was five and six on the squad sometimes
they were very heavy hydraulic machines
which were called on gantries by just
operated them on from the gantry and the
holder up they just stopped them and front
of the river and the bottom i could just
simply trying to handle. We had very very
large. Oil furnaces there which would
hold up to half
a bag of rivets or time all of us and then
the pure magic shop in the small shop
well that was all more and more still there.
They had the same. There's only phone
a squat there but they had the same
methods of heating the rivets.
And there was the head of the ribbons the
catch boy which was considerable distance
away sometimes. And they put it. Now the
hold up put on with his machine and just
took the pressure and the river which
was the tribesmen down the muddy job of
knocking it down which means and i've
tried doing the job of making the river
forming
a rounding ahead of can you remember the
accuracy with which the job had to be done
. Yes accuracy events
a group of my eastleigh all
jobs and their buildings
shipbuilding got
a sixteenth clearance and there were the
clouds. But on the harbour bridge. They
all have a thirty second
clearance. And we never had
a reamer on the job through the magnificent
marking off and the drilling of the men
in the lightship. And you in the heavy
shot was it did it come through to you as
plates or was it already. Partly bolted up
or was sectionals it was all sectionals
. It was no no. Only place came through
there was all built in sections and in the
light shop and they were pushed through
to the heavy shop where they were joined
together again the roof further assembled
until they were complete want of
a set to remember any machined or drilled
plates being brought from from great
britain from middlesbrough no i've
as one fellow i interviewed recently
who worked in the endowment lungs in
middle and he said that he was working for
three years on drilling patris plates
whatever there. Well i could have the could
have but every plate they took off the ships
of the side of the light shop were all
marked off in the light shop and any and
it struck your work out there. Well i
didn't see if anything came through the
shops were all marked of their. I want to
follow this business through of these
buttress plates to try and get some
resolution. Do you understand what
a patris plate is no i don't. All
right well the bloke who was who
was doing this drilling talks about the
plates that were what that was standard
which were on the transverse frames on the
joints which were up on the bridge there
were some some plates which covered
over the joint matter but battered
but when they met when they met they have
to put the coming plate on not and then
they were half worried all right well
according to him. These plates which were
standard throughout the job were all drilled
in uk. Can you imagine that this might
be so i know the answer could. Yes because
they were all staying with all the way
through so that it could be right there
but it's just an amazing thing. And i'd
never seen my been in there in that shot
from every river put in the last one and i
never saw any any place coming through there
because they could have all they would
have been joined up on the job. Wouldn't
they. There's those but you know not
necessarily half half of might be joined
here and then i feel it in then the other
half or really that's really how they joined
now but at the moment there. Yes well
this is
a mystery. I'd say no. Yes well he
reckons he was working for three years
on drilling. Jobs for in the bridge
department for the rich i will be repetition
because they were there assembled in the
bottom shop and we riddled them. It's i
know that there were some things
that definitely were done over
a nuke and that check that out and one of
the things was the pipes which acted as
guides for them for the cables. These
pipes were made into a gigantic frame and
a hundred twenty eight cables passed. Two
sets of these down into the tunnels and
they were made in the uk. I suppose they
must have been an awful lot of drilling
and that would be yes that would be there
was another job which i also know was was
was made in the uk and this is the angle
pass which kept the position of the rods
that bolted the bearings in from the bottom
they reckon that they were all those
angles were all drilled in the u.k.
Also yes because of the shop work we done
nothing whatsoever on the bottom. On the
base but this buttress place that has me
baffled that so. Well it could be but i
never so. Can you remember any of the other
staff around the workshop there and his
staff. Yes out. Joe phelps no he was on
the it was the other even the inspector.
Said thompson out martin. And who were
your riveters in the shop do you remember.
Yeah bob mcdonnell.
There's only but being done and
a few of the names are so long ago they
were coming and going and i just can't
recollect many more names.
Really hold it now. Did any of
your men go out on the on the
arch afterwards. Oh yes yes yes.
John yates even the arch.
And george got was
a two from the shop the only two went up
from the shop the calico from the shop now
. Blowing on the outside. He started on
the erection. Shouted more. All those
routers out there. They all started from
the other side. Do you remember the day
that kelly fell. I remember it very well
very well indeed. Yes. Please tell us
about that. Yeah sure. And you kelly. We
are we call them net for short. He fell
on for bridge but he might as well add
that this momo and him were very good
commerce and they were exceptionally
good rivers i tried but they had
a little bit of
a knock on each other because they were
both exceptionally good divers and swimmers
and they belong to a club in balmain and
a certain amount of jealousy
between them. But i have
a they're working as workmates they were
good covers. But when kelly fell in in the
harbor. I had been speaking to him previously
several occasions and they tell me
that the emphasis about what he would do
any event of falling out. And exactly.
That was exactly what happened because
he fell in feet first. They reckoned his
boots were also unsound sound
so which they were a strawman
a punt and this more on the top
a took six member holding back because he
wanted to jump in after to save his life
by the way this momo rieu dived into
into time just one day at lunch time
a cockatoo by diving in from the top of
the titan bigger like rain. But more of
course. Kelly. He came back within
two weeks came back to where it
was entered and with a medal.
I understand i say i met
a lot of people that it's right up here
recover. You got to watch but i think he
got that much from norman long but i know
where he got the medal. I think example
from the insurance company and still have
a million dollars. We wouldn't have got
a million dollars. The next and we would
have got would be sixteen hundred dollars
. Even if we've got killed. Yes that's
a yes. However that was my kelly and these
i don't know if he's still alive. No i'm
not sure i think he died last year. How
much. Well i'm very sorry to hear that he's
a very nice chap. Can you remember the
working conditions in the shop. Yes
wonderful harmonious i never worked on
a better job with harmony and
all my life. We had we have
a working workshop committee. Every trade
was represented and we had a chairman of
a committee epaulette called up the read
and read and was the tool smith very
clever man clever tradesman. And
a great orator and he kept things of peace.
He could talk to the bus and talk to
them. With the result
we never have a strike
a dispute on the highway job on the inside
there's people saying regarding the
outside of the love around of the bridge
on the outside there are bad as they were
today. I'm referring to the latter in early
but aren't the real and the harmony in
the shop perfect. And we had a
manager there martin he was
a very severe and solid manly one of the
pound of flesh. But he socialized with us
all our department
a little social functions we'd housed run
about their sergeants and markets ready
be it a be in attendance. We have
a cricket team and he followed us right
through but the harmony in the shop was
absolutely perfect to play in
a test match did you. I never played the
test. No no no that was more or less the
office they have over on the other side.
They have that test match that we played
and see holmes and we were run
up but when you play we have
a very good team. After dan's up
a down of the leading him on the in the
latch up and he was he played for he played
for us. I'm
a great team here at the time but he can't
stop talk me come back to me organise
just be
a pretty good team. A new member as opposed
to whether there were strikes or whatever
. Do you remember the working conditions
being any different to you know what you
remembered in other jobs or the
conditions were all right.
Today up to date. Well of course you're
thinking of fifty odd years ago were as
they're writing is you've got to put an
older bit of wouldn't think you carried on
. Well knows it was
a sign there in those days. No no. Charters
no clothes no locker rooms or nothing
like that we have today is just the same
as they were on those days any place else
. How did it compare with where you served
your time in the first. Well and when i
was serving my apprenticeship. You
simply have at work about four miles of
a job and i get into my working clothes.
One day and went to work and my working
close knocked off and come out never even
watch my amps. It just simply never work
and the close to moment of what was the
money like when you were on the bridge
row well i was getting as
a foreman i was getting there. I don't
know. I wasn't really on
the staff but i missed
a day i was always paid of you understand
but i'd work every saturday morning. The
boys were in there and i bring a couple of
a couple of squads and every week i
think about six six pounds for that as
a form mine was was in pretty good.
Whenever i went to new guinea with such
standing pay there and they
were giving us six pounds ten
a week to go into new guinea to
work but you know my six pounds
a week was pretty good. You know fact
therefore you were getting about the pound
two pounds less than the people are
working on the arch. Yes. Well they were
working and then i got up. That was the
conclusion they got through as i'm telling
you those strikes and strikes and strikes
that was at the conclusion of the job.
Early on they weren't getting anything like
the money. I was getting more than them
for so much. To rember of the
other accidents. Oh yes it
was not it wasn't really many actions in
the shop. But i remember one of the little
scotch fellow men. He was working in the
heavy shop and they were preparing to take
a lift. Don't put it on the punt and i
don't know what it was about the rapala
little plate had them cut them on the leg
and they happened to tiger but it turned
out pretty bad it was pretty bad in there.
He had to lose his job and that to be
looked after and when the boys jumped
in every week and kept them. All right
another one another bad one was
a living hand rigger and there's no
riggers in the shop and he was a kind of
a chain chaser
a crane chaser. But he was supervising
they taken the plates off the boats when
they came in the side of the chopper and
he was on the punt and lincoln ran to hit
them and knock them in and they picked them
up there the next day it was really all
i didn't know. You remember from
there. Where did you live at the time
you get to work and lived in what i tell
right on the job right and then the right
job we got up out of bed and simply
feeling. The job. She's a wonderful person
was as far as she treated us well as
a matter of fact
a lot of these fellows make that they
demonstrate as i did they made application
projects in england and they tell me of
the commodity or make up location which
they did and i gave them
a job. Mostly all british boys scotch
english irish belfast like myself. And
when they get out here argument
germany might send them
a bring them up to the hotel and this hotel
was muddy place reasonable and she met
with these families when they came out
here they didn't know where they where she
looked after what was the name of the hotel
they imperial right down at the gate as
you go in. That's right. We're in
a park is now. She's one of the water her
family which is well known in sydney know
that she is the mother of the late charles
charles if they had the young fellow but
a rather two sons billy which
is well known and jack about
big time but my guess. It may make
a film on the rails. And she had
a daughter also betty which was
a very charming girl too. She still
alive. But that was mr water she was
a wonderful person she mother the lot of
them they ask you. Sometimes they ask you
what happened during the lunch ask in the
shops but we never knew we always went up
another lovely lunch was every day. Do
you remember in the workshops there
that you had. Well alright so
used to come up at lunchtime
to the imperial so you didn't know what
went on doing lunch. Did you know any other
extracurricular activities that used to
go on there during working hours. Oh yes
yes yes there's
a very good esprit bookmaker up shop. We
have another one down in the heavy shop
also others to bookmakers on there within
hours. One was oh i forget his name now
but my memory is gone but he was up on
them and they have patronized him all the
bustle. But damn good went down on
the latch up. I've been there for
a long long while but one of the early
release it on the ass playing and the fellow
that picked up the rivets and brought on
the furnaces he got the best for i want to
give you forget the name of that
the bookie in their vision.
If you're getting your own next. Jeremy
when the art was close. Did they give you
a mento in those days. Ah yes
yes i got a medal from mr.
Freeman. And i meant it was a form of
a canberra to bob the date of the locking
of the archers on the nine i'm foreman on
it. I still go with the i believe. Do you
remember if you get the day after day to
do for the rest of the day.
Yes we're going to have
a day off. You know with it sure yeah.
As you say with the only frontier we got
tight. Play out of that.
Well as anzac day they all.
Rather funny all all the extra girls of
the first world war there were laid open
arms that day they go to the light of
morning off they go to the cenotaph. Every
back in the shop was
a soldier. So they all knocked off and
they never came back and that day but they
they got a day off before anzac day was
a holiday. It's my birthday so i
reckon it should should be encouraged
. The at the workshops. Do you have anything
to do with the any of the stone masons
are as you know know now they were they
worked outside so that the fact the stones
were already in the plane that the maria.
And then they can do only on the bus and
they just place them in position. You didn't
have anything to do with them. Do you
have anything to do with the people who
worked on the approaches at all. No women
at the public works do you have anything
to do with the public works people are
they were my opposition to satisfy our
military were very very very serious boys.
Everything was accurate on the bridge and
up to 100 percent of happily 100 per cent
for them every rule that was tested and
the very very few rejected very few
. How many how many rivets were rejected
you know i couldn't tell you i mean he was
rejected at the very very little you take
six million me that's put in the job and
i chide they could have been a
few. But there was one occasion
a couple of my memory i have of
the case of gone erection and
a couple of times these inspectors
came and they tested every rivet with
a hammer. And at with the usual low procedure
and i tried and different places to
tighten the rivet we got to select one.
It just put a tool and hit it with
a hammer and it made
a little mark and it wasn't detected by
much. And the type the type written up. But
these rivers were so heavy
and so big that you got
a big scale on them when they got hot and
that get that scale ok you just hit them
on a plate and it didn't at the
head of my little bit just
a tiny little bit and when they get when
they could off that same mark was on which
with which we represent as we've
been marking. And it took me quite
a want to discover that or it would
have been a big big big fault have been
a big blue i was but we found out and they
were great the place was what it was so
in actual fact they didn't reject them
for that they were not. They couldn't
because they were perfect only for that
little mark which was quite it was in the
trade that that was the math at the time
on the map. What happened if you say
overheated to rivet what would
happen if there were heated
a rivet. I could never never just simply.
You could put the rivet in there and
would burn away and not run out. Well if
it got burned at all. It had to be thrown
away. Yeah well it never they never get
they get the period we never get another
show any time but that was what that's what
would happen. There's those we put half
a bag or ever since that time. There's
those that say over the harbor that the
amount of burnt ones that were checked
over the side. You could have
a bridge alone on a over the
over the and i burnt with
a burnt with it if you put up
a river in coke. You'll burn it on the point
and it will all swell up and burn burn
but when you put it in the same heat all
the way you can't get it by the church
just simply melt but it
won't burn. When you
light off off the bridge then the work of
a riveting work was completed in the shop.
Absolutely. Complete. I left work on
friday night and i got
on the big jury doing
a maiden voyage in new guinea on the summer
they morning. So i was never off one
minute he had a job of a new guinea.
I went to new guinea for the below
a gal dredging calmly approach me prior
to leaving there i didn't left on the my
own steam and we went to new guinea and
built some bridges up there as up there for
eighteen months. He's anything else that
sticks in your memory or linear amusing
stories that stick in your memory from the
time she worked on the bridge. Do you
meeting dr redfield at all sure
yes. Dr. Brett then went overseas
and i was
a foreman and when he came back. At
used to be my job to meet all these
poor fellows was during the depression as
you well know. And they were all standing
in between the shops them looking for work
fifty sixty a memory morning. And i had
a bad job of telling. Nothing doing that.
No work out chap no work no work. So one
morning was
a little fellow can pass out of the dog on
the can pass just as i told them and the
others have pulled down over his eyes the
usual way war and this little fella came
along and in that now damned work i tell
you people that don't work and have turned
out of a doctor prideful
i was knocking back for
a job he used that story later
understood. Yes yes yes
yes as a matter of fact dr.
Brown people that use it. Many
a time when he's up to dinner speeches i've
heard of myself years. Can you think of
any other funny stories that happened during
the building of the bridge. Oh yes yes
yes this is a goodie. One of these good
fellows. At came out here and i got
a commendation up and mr.
Wharton holmes's. His name is damn the
month i think is still alive. He worked at
a work to bonnaroo powers last time i heard
up and down the month. And i don't mean
live together in the pub and this was
on a monday morning and there was
a jolly good river the stand and was on
a monday morning and i couldn't i couldn't
get them to go to job is just cheeky and
it wasn't them. It just this monday morning.
It just wouldn't do anything in the
front of the squad. He was making me look
a fool and then he invited they want to
fight me want to fight me so i knew damn
and i couldn't stand up and said all right
i'll fight you. So we went up the ramp
went up to the paddock in front of the pub
and he grabbed my hand he said dave you
know i wouldn't fight you each at my
head's bursting he said come another drink
which i did and we can die
and he went to work in
a big hit on the monday. That's as true
as god and they were used to do in
any spare time when you had money and
in those days in sydney. When you were
working on the bridge this money business
on there was days we went dancing made
quite
a lot of plenty of entertainment
where used to go to the ball
ground there at the poly royal and then
come from there at the other place that i
met the fact we used to watch
the fellow that struck
a beer out. Jack we were working on the
bridge when every start of the track at
their own. So we used to go there were
a lot of fun and i was i wasn't
married of course at the time but
tell me about this how tell most
of what has a hotel. What you have
a nice charming little girl surely sixteen.
And this is what i choose to bring up
from in the give and i am making beds at
separate and general work tipple of being
on the bus doesn't really have a
kid and if you want to ask me many
a time one of my take and still is up to
the pictures and i'm with stella and she
take all of the pictures i use a chaperon
a take up in the car or in
pictures i took up quite
a lot. I married the
bugger. If she's still
a charming girl. So it's
a good story and. The orpheum picture
show in sydney you mention where was that
it was right and nearly on the way of the
bridge there and they approach is no
sydney station. I think it's building
and i think it might make way for
a roadway for the bridge but there's another
reference. I don't know whether you
can remember this. There was
a famous fire during the time of the building
of the bridge. It was called the p f
a building fire remember where that
was no now only had a fire and
a hotel up there nearly off in the other
was quite a big fire but it was in
a hotel. You know you can remember. Do you
member any of the other picture places
in town then city. Oh yes
yes yes. Used to go to the.
Usually through we went on
a sunday night but they.
Oh yes we used to get
a bit the capital thing ever used to go
up there and they couldn't charge you on
a sunday night but they had all sorts
of entertainment fights and they had
a they had a animal show
is there and you just put
a silver coin in but little one and then
we went the prince edward they were
building the state there at the time that
we got the prince edward and the really
good show. There was about the fact we saw
the first talking picture of their mummy
show. Other just think it was just so you
know that they were just opposite the
hotel australia. If you did did you pay
extra to go and see that i think we did
the first one leave we were very
impressed with it seems do you remember
any australian films and australian
films that was deb and dave and
the below that sort of stuff but i was
never much we didn't have much them.